mais combien de temps tu peux passer à
jouer a fortement toute la journée
légis surtout les journées d'école ou
jour j sais où j'ai commencé vraiment un
petit essai l'école le temps d'un
extrait de témoignages de l'adolescent
de 13 ans qu'on a rencontré hier au
centre grand chemin où il subit
actuellement une cure contre la
dépendance aux jeux iphone est ce pour
des cas comme celui ci que deux firmes
d'avocats déposé une demande d'actions
collectives contre epic games
les fabricants de ce jeu vidéo qui
connaît vraiment un succès planétaire
alors je joins à paris s'il ya autant
scolaire qui a participé à la conception
de ce jeu forte naïma la mode un bon
jour dont l'interview bonjour on dit de
vous que vous êtes vraiment derrière le
succès du jeu vidéo est fort net avec
ses 250 millions d'utilisateurs dans le
monde avec des milliards de dollars en
revenus
dites nous comment vous réagissez quand
on parle de dépendance de problème
vraiment chez chez les jeunes
comment vous réagissez à sa demande
d'actions collectives
oui déjà premièrement je ne suis pas
tout seul derrière le succès de fontenay
temps c'est un travail d'équipé c'est
compliqué sur de nombreuses années j'ai
participé bien sûr alors pour la
conception du jeu
moi ça me rend triste parce que y'a des
gens qui est des enfants et des
adolescents surtout qu'ils sont qui se
sentent prisonniers du jeu et passent
toute leur journée à jouer c'est sait
jamais ce qu'on souhaite d'un jeu on
souhaite dangereux qu'il apporte du
bonheur du plaisir du fun à la pour la
tranche d'âge cocon qu'on souhaite
atteindre maintenant je comprends tout à
fait de la réception des parents qui n'y
sont un peu démuni quand leur enfant
joue un peu trop longtemps souvent et
des gens qui jouent qui sont très jeunes
madame hazan vous disiez dans une
entrevue sur nos ondes en janvier
dernier que votre défi
en tant que psychologue auprès des
concepteurs c'était de trouver le moyen
de garder les jeunes vraie main dans le
jeu est est ce que est ce que vous
n'êtes pas allé un peu trop loin avec
les concepteurs
dans cette veine là on cherche pas à
garder les jeunes dans le jeu ce qu'on
essaie de faire c'est quand on fait un
jeu comme n'importe quel produit concret
ou ou fils louis en charge de donner du
plaisir pour donner du plaisir et en
assurez la le produit le jouer le jeu à
l'activité soit engageant ci avait pas
engageant ça veut dire qu'on s'ennuie on
n'a pas envie de on n'a pas envie de
jouer donc c'est ça qu'on cherche à
faire
on cherche à faire la porte forte est
typiquement c'est plutôt un jeu destiné
à des jeunes adultes cepal un jeu à la
base dessiné pour info les jeunes
enfants même si comme là c'est pas
beaucoup de violence d'un force night
lire crb a redit que les uns il est à
jouable pour les jeux des jeunes de 13
ans et plus
ce qu'on essaie de faire on utilise des
connaissances en psychologie cognitive
et en ergonomie bas pour s'assurer qu'on
n'a pas de frictions de frustration qui
sont pas des frustrations qu'on veut que
les gens que les joueurs et les joueuses
et et on essaie d'éliminer simple pour
que les jeunes que les joueurs qu'on
traîne les interfaces et le but du jeu
et on essaie de faire en sorte que le
jeu soit motivant parce que si le jeu
n'est pas motivant évidemment on va pas
jouer donc après il ya vraiment deux
choses à comprendre là il ya des il ya
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'ergonomie un
committee vélo idiot axe qui est
appliquée dans énormément de domaines
qui sert aussi pour l'éducation parce
que si un jeu éducatif n'est pas
intéressant et engageant on n'a pas
envie de continuer renforcement à
travers le jeu quand on parle des fameux
coffre à butten c'est de plus en plus
associé aux jeux de loterie on dit en
fait qu'on a utilisé un peu la même
façon de faire ce qui crée une
dépendance est ce que vous vous êtes
maintenant un peu plus sensibilisés à ce
que ça donne comme effet oui alors ça
c'est question 1 2
boxe donc les butins ou des techniques
de ce qu'on appelle utilisé la photo de
firmi saignante en anglais ou en
français la peur de manquer sont des
techniques qui viennent de des
connaissances en fait à vue risque
économique en psychologie de billets
vérisme de l'économie qui sont utilisés
en marketing depuis depuis quand même
énormément de temps et qui as en a trop
dit maintenant dans le jeu vidéo
parce qu'un jeu vidéo coûte très très
cher à produire et maintenant la plupart
des jeux sont gratuits tient beaucoup de
jeux sont gratuits et les joueurs et le
jeu s'attendent à ce que le jeu soit
gratuit et de haute qualité et avec des
contenus qui qui est un rouleau mais
tout le temps et il ya énormément de jeu
de studio qui ferment et des des hommes
des employés donc des créateurs de jeu
des artistes des designers des designers
et des ingénieurs et des programmes aux
qui sont mis à la porte
donc il est les développeurs de jeux et
c'est de mettre en place des systèmes
pour gagner de l'argent lors très on
l'avait questions d'éthique et fit
effectivement kif qui se posent des
anglais qui sont liées à ce qu'on
appelle l'économie de l'attention que
tristan harris dans la silicon valley
commence à parler de ce genre de choses
parce que le jeu vidéo n'est pas le seul
vous parlez de la santé aussi un pain
vous en tant que cap ce cas là qu'on va
terminer à thème à la mode en mai est-ce
que vous avez quand même un cas de
conscience d'avoir travaillé à
l'élaboration d'un jeu comme celui là
qui peut créer de la dépendance
alors surtout par projet la fota qui
compte
moi je travaille sur l'aspect aux fans
du jeu je travaille pas sur ceux de de
bagdad l'accrochage etc je n'aime pas
travailler sur ça je préfère le travail
et sur comment comment faire en sorte
qu'un jeu soit amusant et fans et
déclare en sorte que les joueurs et les
joueuses maxxess des choses
intéressantes qui permettent aussi de
développement dans le mythe il faut pas
l'oublier interagir avec deux personnes
à faire construire des des choses dans
le jeu c'est créatif on se coordonne
pour un pour faire des objectifs moi
c'est ça qui m'intéresse je travaillais
indicatif je travaille là dedans ça ne
m'intéresse pas d'utiliser cette
technique pour ce qu'on appelle des dark
pas terme les patterns un peu obscur
mais c'est comme n'importe quoi la
psychologie cognitive et les
connaissances en psychologie peuvent
être utilisées pour faire en sorte de
faire un monde meilleur faire en sorte
d'aider les gens à arrêter de fumer ou à
manger plus équilibré ou recyclés comme
ça peut être utilisé pour les faire
acheter des choses en solde pendant
black friday qui n'ont pas forcément
besoin et c'est donc ça a été tellement
le disait lui même qui est d'un peu
qu'il ait pas un problème c'est
l'intention qui n arrivent très bien des
gens merci d'avoir partagé ça avec nous
à ce parterre célia d'un merci beaucoup
je vous en prie au revoir